we are asked to draw the image of
triangle abc under a dilation whose
center is p
and scale factor is one fourth so pause
this video and at least think about how
you would do this you don't have access
to the tool that i do where i can move
this around this is actually from the
khan academy exercise but at least think
about how you would do this draw the
image of triangle a b c
under a dilation whose center is p and
scale factor is 1 4.
all right now let's work through this
together so one way to think about it is
we our center of dilation is p and our
scale factor is 1 4. so for each of
these points however far they were from
p before they're now going to be 1 4 as
far
and one way to think about it is is to
think about it in each of the x and the
y dimensions so for example point a
right over here to get from point p to
point a you have to go one two three 4
to the right and 1
2
3 4 down
so 1 4 of that in the x and the y
direction instead of going 4 to the
right and 4 down 1 4 of that would be 1
to the right and 1 down because one is
one fourth of four so instead of four to
the right we'd go one to the right
instead of four down we would go one
down so this is what point a would get
mapped to and now let's think about
point b in order to go from p to point b
you have to go in the y direction up one
two three four five six
seven eight
well what's one fourth of eight
it's two so now we're going to go up two
and to go from p to b how much do we
have to go in the x direction well we
have to go to the left one
two three
four so instead of going four to the
left we're not going to go one fourth of
that or just one to the left so instead
of 8 up and 4 left we're now going 2 up
and 1 to the left 1 4 in each direction
and then last but not least to go from p
to c looks like we're going 1 2 three
four
five six seven eight to the left and one
two three four up
so if we take one fourth of each of
those instead of eight to the left we're
now going to go two to the left instead
of 4 up we're now going to go
1 up and we're done we have just created
the image of triangle abc under dilation
who centers p and scale factor is 1 4.